come here
I would never say this to her face but
she is a wonderful person and a gifted
artist why why wouldn't you say that to
her face so
hey hey
go
go pam pam
hey
what happened I thought you could buy
Pawn it's really long I left it
up in my office could you just please
wait till I go get it I should really
get going no
okay okay
um
the last word is seagulls
I'm sure it was really lovely I took a
lot from other poems
call me when you get in okay bye all
right no Mike
okay Michael you know what I might have
someone for you
oh really what's her name Burger King no
I mean it
she's really nice and sweet and
you guys might actually get along
I don't I don't think I'm ready is she
hot
I'm setting Michael up with my landlady
she's really sweet and
whatever I just can't take Michael like
this
oh no what
I'm going with him
what Pam going
Pam
can't be serious Michael wait
I'm coming with you
you are
yeah
okay it's gonna be great
great uh except I I don't want to be a
receptionist anymore
right
executive assistant salesman
all right
okay
deal deal
okay well Jim still know okay yeah
well let's go
oh all my stuff is still upstairs
for watching probably
Michael it's not how you leave in office
yeah Jam
we're having a company meeting here
I'm gonna bring all your stuff home okay
all right I'll see you later see you
later
Pam you come in here please
have a seat okay
well there's no easy way of saying this
so I think I will just
drag it out
since the dawn of time just tell me
I gave Ryan the sales job
there just weren't enough clients for
the two of you so I had to
okay sorry I'm sorry I get it yeah
foreign
why are you giggling
is this a joke
Michael is this
did I get the job
yes I did yeah for real you're not
kidding
I did you're the best person for the job
you're gonna be great okay thank you
thank you thank you
oh man oh that was classic oh I really
thought I didn't get it oh really yeah
because you said I did that was really
good what about Ryan
I don't know I offered him his temp job
back we'll see he was not happy at all
when I offered him this job and then I
told him that he didn't get the job
though yeah maybe you shouldn't fake
fire people anymore I don't appreciate
you telling me what to do so clean out
your desk you are through here
thanks Michael
receptor's name Erin could you send her
in
you're the one who said we needed more
culture this is culture to you it's her
first try
on Van Gogh's first try he drew the
hands of the peasants meaning what
meaning real art takes courage okay and
honesty well those aren't have strong
points yeah exactly that's why this is
Motel art
thanks for coming
foreign
Caso
sorry I'm late I had to race across town
oh Michael
wow
you did these freehand
yep my God these could be tracings
oh
look at this one
oh
you nailed it
how much
what do you mean
I don't see a price
um you want to buy it well yeah
yeah we have to have it for the office
on me there's my window and there's my
car
is that your car uh-huh
that is our building
and we sell paper
I'm really proud of you
thank you
what
do you have something in your pocket
do I have no thank you
it is a message
it is an inspiration it is
a source of beauty
and without paper
it could not have happened
unless you had a camera
they say on your deathbed you never wish
you spent more time at the office
but I will
gotta be a lot better than a Deathbed
I actually don't understand Death Beds
I mean who would buy that
well
I guess this is it
hey will you guys let me know if this
ever airs
thank you
all right oh
this is gonna feel so good getting this
thing off my chest
foreign
no he wasn't sad
he was full of Hope
about Colorado
and he was hoping to get an upgrade as
an awards member
and he said he was just real excited to
get home and see Holly
[Music]